Oh, Noel, I've got the best idea
for the opening, for the final.
Okay, talk me through it.
Okay, I've got this giant cannon, right?
You get in the cannon
and I fire you out of it.
Fire me out of the cannon?
Don't look at me like that.
It's not exactly rocket science.
Well, obviously,
it is actually rocket science...
-Anyway I've got this giant match. I...
-Is it giant or are you just quite small?
-[Noel chuckles]
-Could you get in the cannon?
All right. This is not the helmet
I would've chosen.
Everything's about fashion. You ready?
In you get.
-Sure about this?
-Okay, I'm lighting it now.
Here we go.
-[cannon booming]
-[Noel screaming]
-[clattering]
-Oh, my shins!
[exhales] Welcome to the final
of the Great British Baking Show.
-Sandi?
-Yeah?
I can't get down. I'm stuck in a tree.
I'll get you a ladder.
-[Noel] When?
-[Sandi] You know... Eventually.
[Noel] In the beginning
of our tenth year...
It's gonna sink, it's gonna sink,
it's gonna sink.
Oh, what a dog's dinner that is.
[clattering]
...we had a baker's dozen.
[siren wailing]
[whimpers]
Now...
David, David, David, David.
Ooh, thank you very much, Noel.
...there are three.
It's not fine. [whimpers]
Shall I put it back in?
I don't know. I don't know.
Ow!
-[exhales sharply]
-[Alice] Trying to stay calm,
but my heart is like, dum-dum-dum-dum-dum.
[theme music playing]
[indistinct chatter]
-Good luck.
-You, too.
I woke up this morning
and I was just kind of like, "Oh, my God,
it's the final." Like, "It's here."
Yeah, there's gonna be
a lot of flapping, let's be honest,
but it would be insane, like,
it would be amazing to win.
[Steph] This is it.
And no, I can't believe it.
It's a battle of many things
but who doesn't wanna win it?
Come on, baking fairies.
Jump on my shoulders. [chuckles]
I've had daydreams about winning
for ten years.
I'm definitely the underdog.
Alice and Steph
with all their star bakers,
all sparkly, they're sparkly girls.
I want to just enjoy everything
about this weekend.
And if I win, I win.
[Sandi] Three remaining bakers
facing three final challenges
before one is crowned
the Great British Baking Show winner 2019.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
-Congratulations.
-Whoo!
-[Noel] You're in the final.
-[Sandi] Ah!
I cannot believe we made it.
I can't believe I made it.
No, and I wrote lots of letters about it.
Er, for this wonderful signature
we would like you to make
the ultimate chocolate cake.
Now, obviously it is the grand final,
so it needs to be a masterpiece.
The Mona Lisa of chocolate cakes.
By that we mean a chocolate cake
that looks like a green woman
with no eyebrows
[Sandi] Exactly that.
Your cake needs to be creative,
it needs to be impressive
and beautifully decorated
to a professional standard.
-You only have two hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
Oh, it's just such madness
that the final has now started
and we're in it. Oh, crazy.
I'm really excited.
I just need to get this cake
in the oven super-fast.
Got so many things going on.
[Prue] Chocolate cake.
It sounds so simple,
but we don't want
a bog standard chocolate cake.
What we want is something
which is really chocolatey,
really decadent,
absolutely astonishingly-good flavour
and, of course, it's got to be decorated
to be worthy of winning the final.
[Paul] I think
using cocoa is a possibility,
but I'd like to see chocolate
in there as well.
Don't make this easy, do they?
[Paul] The baking is integral on this.
Keeping 'em all even
and making sure it's all beautiful
on the outside as well as the in.
It's gonna be all about timing.
You've got to get it right,
there is no room for error.
Two hours is quite tight.
Right. This is a rich cake.
One thing I don't like is when
chocolate cake doesn't taste of chocolate.
It's just a sponge that's brown.
Brown sponge. Not my thing.
[Sandi] Their choice of chocolate
will not only determine
the intensity of their sponge flavour...
Chocolate cake should be moist and rich.
...but the all-important texture, too.
My favourite chocolate cake
that I've just always done,
is this recipe and it's just cocoa powder.
There is quite a lot of it in there.
So it does make it almost a bit fudgy.
-[Paul] Hello, David.
-Hello, Paul.
-[Prue] Hello, David.
-Hey, guys.
[Noel] You're in the final.
Yeah.
Tell us about your grand final
chocolate cake.
So, my chocolate cake is going to be
prune with Armagnac.
Lovely.
The chocolate, what are you using?
I'm going with the 70% cocoa
solid chocolate inside the cake,
-[Paul] Yeah.
-...and cocoa powder as well.
Then it's dark chocolate for the ganache
and dark chocolate for the mirror glaze.
[Noel] David's indulgent
dark chocolate cake
will be flavoured with Armagnac
and vanilla syrup,
and filled with Armagnac cream
to complement prunes
soaked in even more Armagnac.
Where's the prunes?
[David] The prunes are inside the sponge.
Is it well distributed or do you find
it tends to lump round in the bottom?
-It kind... I don't know...
-That's a trick question.
They should go really, like,
mushy into the cake.
So if the prunes go to the bottom,
we won't know anyway.
-[David] Yeah.
-Thank you very much, David.
-Cool, thank you. Thanks.
-[Noel] Good luck.
[Sandi] Also getting fruity with her
grand final chocolate cake is Alice.
I don't really know
how many pears I'm using.
Quite a few.
[Sandi] But she's making sure
it stands out.
So, there's pears in the batter,
there's pears in between the layers
and then there's poached pears on top.
It's interesting to see how the pear's
gonna work with the chocolate.
You normally get that,
almost, like, in a pudding.
Mmm-hmm.
So to see it in a cake,
it's gonna be interesting.
[Sandi] Alice's pear-packed
ginger-flavoured chocolate sponge
will be decorated with
a dark chocolate ganache drip,
maple cream cheese buttercream
and shards of hazelnut brittle,
as well as pears
poached in red wine and cinnamon.
Gotta get the combination
of all the flavours spot on.
I think they seemed to like the ideas.
You never really know, though,
how much they give away.
Ooh, I'm all nervous now. Urgh.
[Noel] When it comes to her
chocolate cake flavours...
Sometimes we just have to acknowledge
the true classics.
...Steph isn't taking any chances.
My chocolate cake is gonna be
a black forest chocolate cake.
It's a '70s dream, innit?
[Paul] It is something
that used to get wheeled round
-with your prawn cocktail and your steak.
-[Steph] Yeah.
That came round as well
with your cheeseboard.
-Thought that was pretty cool.
-And me pushing the trolley.
Wait, you were a trolley dolly, were you?
-[Prue] Well...
-[Paul laughs]
[Noel] Steph's retro cake
will be coated in chocolate ganache
and full of classic black forest flavours,
with cherry jam
and kirsch-spiked Chantilly cream.
Gold leaf-gilded cherries will finish
her grand final signature bake.
It probably is the most important cake
I've had to bake, but
mum would just be saying,
"Just enjoy it. Stay calm."
I definitely couldn't have done this
without my mum's support.
That's what's made it
all the more possible for me, I think.
-My God!
-So embarrassing.
Just got resting misery face from you,
didn't I?
I know.
[Noel] It's not the first time
Steph's mum has been
cheering her on from the sidelines.
I couldn't wish for
a better daughter than Steph.
I cannot tell you how close we are.
And this experience has probably
brought us closer together out of anything
'cause I've had to do
an awful lot of washing up
and scraping her off the floor.
[chuckles]
-It's gonna be absolutely perfect.
-Yeah.
[Jane] She was not in a good place
this time, last year.
Not knowing what to do with her life,
and she started to cook things
and it helped her.
But the experience of being in Bake Off,
it's life changing.
If people could see how far she's come
as a person, they wouldn't believe it.
She's got it all
and doesn't think she's got anything.
And there's no reason why she can't win.
I'd just cry.
[chuckles] I would.
I'm crying now at the thought of it.
[all] Cheers.
-All the luck in the world, darling.
-Yeah.
[sniffling] Oh.
You'd have thought I'd be capable
of anything after this, wouldn't you?
Nerves still very much jangling.
Oh, what are we going to do
about your confidence?
I think I used to get like it
with athletics as well.
I was always nervous
that I was gonna hit a hurdle,
which I did do this one time.
Got to the last hurdle and I was like,
"I'm never gonna get over that,"
so I just went through it and then did
a tumble turn, sort of got up.
It's just like dropping your cake
at the showstopper?
Oh, please. Please. You've just said it.
[whispers] Okay.
In we go.
Twenty-three minutes.
or until a skewer comes out clean.
[Sandi] With time slipping away...
I'm in after 25 minutes.
So, five minutes ahead.
...the bakers' ultimate chocolate cakes...
Ooh, a lot of butter.
...are about to get even more indulgent...
Look how glossy
and beautiful that looks now.
...with the creation
of their luxurious fillings.
[David] I'm making my ganache icing.
Growing up, if we had cake,
you only had icing
if it was a birthday cake.
My mum likes to remove
every bit of sugar and fat
and it's quite funny 'cause then
she complains that a recipe isn't good.
It's like, well, that's not the recipe.
You've just removed half the ingredients.
-[David] That is the perfect consistency.
-[Judy] That's wonderful.
I would've gone like that.
That's wonderful, though.
[Noel] David's been honing
his baking skills from an early age.
[Judy] When all the children
were very little, we always baked.
And he was always very able
and very creative.
-[Richard] First class.
-Outstandingly good, wasn't he?
[Richard] Yeah. He was doing
art and design for a year,
then he decided
he didn't want to go into that world.
-Hmm.
-And he turned to nursing.
[Judy] He would rather do something
and make a difference to people's lives.
We're very proud of what he's done.
We think the world of him, don't we?
-Think he's great.
-Yes. Yes.
[Nik] He's just worked very, very hard.
So he's working his job, but then also
he's preparing for Bake Off all the time.
So, I think that can be a lot.
But he's been just super-driven
and just gone for it.
To David, the baking genius
because of Mum's food snobbery.
[everyone laughing]
[David] I'm also putting Armagnac
in the ganache.
So, this was full when we started.
And I've not finished yet.
-Sandi, what you doing?
-What?
It's the final. You need to look
a bit cooler, yeah?
-Oh.
-Sunglasses on.
Oh, sorry.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[David] Halfway through.
What are those?
You look like the secret love child
of Timmy Mallet and a bumblebee.
Right, where are we?
So we got all that, that, that.
Oh, doing too many things at once.
[Noel] Not only do David,
Steph and Alice have to
constantly check their sponges...
Should be okay.
...and fillings...
Yum.
...to truly impress Prue and Paul...
You always make me so nervous.
...their cakes will have to look
as flawless and decadent on the outside
as they are on the inside.
[Alice] I'm making poached pears.
They sit on top of the cake.
Whoops, whoops. Making a mess.
Wouldn't be me, if I didn't make
a mess everywhere, would it?
[Jane] Would you just explain, Alice,
what you've done?
I put some scales
on the little chocolatey fish.
There's no mess. I think you tidied up
before this was taken.
[laughing] I know!
[Sandi] Alice has been
baking and decorating cakes
since she was a child.
[Henry] Baking is her passion.
She finds it very easy to put
the effort in and the discipline in.
We've always taught Alice to prepare well,
think things through.
The magic words we have for her
is good management.
With good management,
you don't need good luck.
[Jane] You were determined
to win that trophy.
She can win it.
She'll go out there
and give it her absolute best.
We are so proud of her.
Love her to bits,
and wishing her lots and lots
of good management.
[chuckling]
-[chuckling]
-[Alice] That's too much.
What?
-[chuckling]
-Don't laugh at me.
This is me in my natural state, okay?
Panic attack. I'm having
a panic attack. [laughing]
Just don't get too close.
[Steph] Just pray for me.
Baking fairies, pray for me.
[Alice] Okay, I'm just gonna
take one out and check.
[David] Yes.
So they're all coming out.
[Alice] I just don't know
if this one's done.
I'm worried that it's not baked properly.
You can smell the Armagnac.
It's all about chilling time now.
[Alice] Oh, yeah. I think it's fine.
Oh, no, it's not. It's not fine.
[whimpers]
Shall I put it back in?
I don't know. I don't know.
[sing-song] One thing I forgot!
[Alice] Shall I just bake another one?
No, 'cause it won't cool in time.
Silly idea.
[David] This is a syrup
that I forgot to do.
It's just more Armagnac.
[Noel] David, David, David, David.
Ooh, thank you very much, Noel.
That's fine.
I think I'll start again.
[Alice] Gonna have to put it back in.
This is a little bit unconventional.
Oh, I really hope
that just pulls itself together.
[Noel] You do the time call,
I'll pretend to be The Scream
by Edvard Munch.
Seems reasonable.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
[Steph] Oh, assembly time.
[David] I don't want loads and loads
of cream here, 'cause it's very strong.
Definitely has a kick.
[Steph] As straight as it can be.
[scoffing]
[Alice] I think it's done.
If I can get it cool, I'll use it.
If I can't, I'm not using it.
Oh, I just feel all...
[shudders and laughs]
[David] Last week was the first time
I ever did a mirror glaze.
This is the first time
I'm doing a chocolate mirror glaze.
This has got to go down to 32.
At the moment, it's at...
-Forty-seven.
-[David chuckles]
That's gotta go down a hell of a lot.
Can I have some ice?
Who did you say that to?
There's nobody there.
[laughing] Weird.
-Just talking to people?
-Yeah.
Okay. I'll get you some ice.
Okay, how long do we actually have left?
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
[Alice whimpers]
It's cold, thank God.
I'm gonna start putting it all together.
This can be my middle layer.
Hopefully, you won't see it too much.
Phew.
[David] Last week, right at the end,
I just rushed it,
and Paul picked up on that.
[Alice] Why are you doing this to me?
It's just leaning.
[Steph] Oh, my God. I'm shaking.
[David] Can you see my reflection?
Yeah, I can.
[Alice] I think it's that middle layer.
Trying to stay calm, but my heart
is like dum-dum-dum-dum-dum.
Bakers, you have one minute.
[Steph] It's nearly there.
[Alice] Maybe if I cover it in ganache,
they won't notice?
[Steph] Think that's me finished.
[exhales]
[Alice] Oh, this is just not fun.
[David] Whoa. It's kind of
stuck to the paper of the cake board.
[Alice] Bake Off final, everyone.
[David] Just gonna have
to put it across anyway.
Bakers, time is up.
Done.
Please place your luscious
masterpiece chocolate cakes
at the end of your benches.
[exhales]
I've made a million cakes in my life.
And this is the one that matters.
Maybe it will taste nice?
[Noel] It's judgment time
for the bakers' final signature challenge.
-Hello, David.
-Hi.
[exhales]
I think it's quite effective.
[Prue] It's a really good shine.
And the leaves actually look
quite nice on it as well.
[gasps] Can't wait, come on.
-Give us a bite.
-[Paul] Let's have a look.
[Prue] Look at that.
[Paul] It looks very good inside.
-You can smell the Armagnac, can't you?
-[David chuckling]
Mmm.
That Armagnac,
you wouldn't miss it, David.
-[Prue chuckles]
-[Sandi] Is there enough?
[chuckles] There's slightly
more than enough.
[Paul] I think when you do hit a prune,
it is delicious.
I think all your textures are beautiful,
but all you're getting is alcohol.
[Prue] It is so boozy
that you can only eat
a tiny little bit of it.
So a bit of ice cream or something?
-Would that work?
-[Prue] Hmm.
-Chocolate ice cream, probably.
-[all laughing]
[Paul] Thank you very much.
-[David] Thanks, guys.
-Thanks, David.
First impression, it's a bit wobbly.
-[Alice] Hmm.
-[Prue] And it's a bit clumsy.
[Paul] I like the dripping effect.
I think it looks quite nice
and there is a bit of a shine there.
There's a lot going on, on the top.
You're usually so delicate.
Okay.
-But it may taste fantastic.
-[Alice chuckles]
[Paul] Let's see, shall we?
[Prue] The knife's going in
beautifully there.
Wow.
The texture of the cake's lovely,
isn't it?
Mm.
Very light.
[Paul] You didn't have, erm,
real chocolate in this,
-did you?
-No.
Cocoa.
-Do you think it could be more chocolatey?
-Yeah.
-I'm lacking the chocolate, actually.
-Okay.
Because you've got maple,
because you've got a little bit of ginger,
because you've got pear,
and then you put cocoa in there,
it's a great cake.
-[Alice] Yeah.
-But is it a great chocolate cake?
I think it's delicious.
I think it is a really good balance
between chocolate and pear and ginger.
My main problem with it
is actually the way it looks.
-Yeah.
-Not the way it tastes.
-Thank you, Alice.
-Thank you very much.
[Prue] It's very '70s.
It's a sort of old-fashioned cake.
But that's what you were doing
and you've done it beautifully.
[Paul] It's very elegant,
but let's have a look inside, shall we?
Three pretty distinctive layers in there.
[Prue] Yeah. Cherry jam looks beautiful.
That's a black forest gateau.
[Paul] You've certainly got
the chocolate there.
And the cherries and the cream
work well together.
There's a good balance.
It's very crumbly, that cake.
I think it is slightly overbaked,
but the flavour of the chocolate
is delicious.
It's a very nice cake, Steph.
-Okay, thanks.
-[Paul] Very good.
-Thank you.
-[Steph] Thanks, guys.
Slightly like, "Ugh, that's annoying."
I always want it to be perfect. [sighs]
Just got to remember to try and enjoy it.
[David] There was too much alcohol.
It would've been a hard thing to do,
but just be like,
"I'm just gonna do chocolate."
Maybe I should've done that.
[Alice] The technical for the final,
there's no theme this week.
It could literally be anything,
which is terrifying.
I hope they don't throw
a massive curveball.
[Sandi] For our final three bakers,
the pressure is about to rise.
Right, bakers, welcome to your
very final technical challenge.
Today, it's been set for you
by the delight that is Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
On this challenge,
you have to be delicate.
[Noel] Okay, as ever, gonna have to ask
these two numpties to leave the tent.
-Off you pop, kids.
-Bye.
-That's you two. All right.
-Hello.
[chuckling]
[all laughing]
[laughing continues]
Sorry. I couldn't keep it up, Paul.
Ah, that was like a weird dream.
Okay, today, Paul would love you to make
six twice-baked Stilton souffls.
Your souffls need to hold their shape
when they're turned out of the mould,
but they need to be delicate
and fluffy in texture.
And each one must be served with
a thin lavosh cracker.
[Noel] You have an hour and ten.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Bake!
I've got a friend.
We were living in a flat together
and he was looking for his souffl dish
and it turned out
I'd used it as a plant pot.
I'd no idea what it was.
It's probably one
of the hardest technicals.
Very limited time, shaking like a leaf,
all the standard stuff.
Help me.
Paul, this is the final,
and you've given us
a twice-baked Stilton souffl.
Why?
[Paul] I wanted something
that was gonna challenge them
but also had a very classic feel to it.
What we're looking for
are very proud, tall souffls,
with a gorgeous golden-brown colour
coming from the cream and the parmesan.
What could go wrong, then?
[Paul] When you're making a souffl,
what you've gotta remember
is, er, whisking your egg whites.
If you don't whisk them enough,
it's not gonna carry the air,
but, again, if you overbeat it,
you're gonna have a similar problem.
Be delicate with that mixture.
They could be underbaked
when we tip them out.
Therefore, when they coat them
with the cream and the parmesan,
you're gonna be coating a splat.
They need to concentrate
and watch their ovens.
-It's a bigger piece for you there, Prue.
-[Prue] I'm a bigger girl.
[Paul laughing]
But you see the air holes in it.
It's quite a stable structure as well.
And then you have
these gorgeous lavosh biscuits
which are really wafer-thin.
A few bubbles all over it,
and a great snap as well.
I'm hoping we're gonna
come up with something
that at least tastes good.
-Oh, I think they'll be lovely.
-[Paul chuckles]
I think this is first, isn't it?
Make a roux.
[David] A roux is what people think of
if they're making a white sauce.
It's used as the base of a souffl.
[Steph] You melt your butter,
add your flour.
I hope the roux will thicken.
We can hope.
I just don't know how thick it should be.
Don't wanna overdo it.
So this is now getting
quite nice and thick.
I just don't think I've done this right.
-[Sandi] What's the matter?
-I just don't know if this is right.
-Is this is a roux?
-[Sandi] Have you never made a roux?
Really? You've never
made lasagne, fish pie?
Any of those things?
-Sauce, bchamel sauce, no?
-[Alice chuckles]
-[speaks indistinctly]
-Lovely weather we're having, isn't it?
[David] Right.
Add parmesan, mustard, chives and thyme.
[Steph] Forty grams of this bad boy.
[David] I'm just gonna give the thyme
a bit of a chop and a bash.
I haven't got time for this.
[Steph] Beat in egg yolks,
mix in Stilton and seasoning.
[Alice] In it goes.
Tasty? Tasty goodness.
-[Steph] Hmm.
-[Noel] It's like an advert from the '70s.
-[Steph] Yeah.
-Mmm, tasty goodness. [chuckles]
-[Noel] Let's have a taste.
-[Alice] Go on then.
-Oh.
-Oh, tasty goodness.
-[Steph] Okay, great, that's brilliant.
-Yeah.
Right, I need to whisk my egg whites.
[David] A souffl doesn't have
any raising agents,
so all of the oomph
comes from the egg white.
[Steph] It's not looking great.
A few lumpy bits in there.
I have this quite a lot.
I think I overwhip my egg whites.
[Alice] It's like a stiff peak, I think.
Does that look all right?
Hmm.
I'm gonna... Yeah,
I'm gonna leave it like that.
It looks quite airy.
Have to get them in the tins, I think.
I don't know how much to put in here.
This is not a one-oh-one
on souffl-making.
How much should I put in, Noel?
Er...
-Oh, God.
-[David] You never put all in
-'cause it would overflow.
-I've got nothing.
They're gonna rise, aren't they?
That's the thing.
I think it doesn't wanna be too much.
[Noel] Doesn't wanna be too much
'cause then they'll go pfft!
-Yeah.
-Mushroomy.
This is a wing-it situation.
-Think I need to probably fill it.
-[Alice] I need a bit of space at the top.
They are gonna rise up.
Fingers crossed.
[exhales]
This one looks like it's
run out of all the airiness,
so shame for this little runt,
but this'll be me
in the family of souffls.
Bake using a bain-marie.
Cold water or hot water?
[David] Hot water in a tray in the oven.
[Alice] Hot water in the bain-marie.
[Steph] Just going for cold water.
[David] They're ready for the first bake.
[Alice] Right, they're going in.
[Steph] I hope it rises.
-[timer beeping]
-I don't know what is gonna happen.
Right, what have I gotta do now
'cause I feel like I'm way behind.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Halfway through.
I've not got long to double-bake these
and make the crackers.
Right, I'm making the dough.
But it kinda sounds really crispy
and actually really delicious,
so I'm happy to make one of these.
Plain flour, wholemeal flour,
olive oil, salt and water,
-but doesn't tell you how much water.
-[David] Roll the dough until paper-thin.
-Do we think this is paper-thin?
-[David] Now is this paper-thin?
Oh, that is paper-thin, darling.
You could...
-Yes.
-That's like parchment.
You could write the dead sea scrolls
on that.
I'd rather do that, than bake souffls.
All right. Twelve equal triangles.
How do we do this?
[David] One thing that is never
my strong point is maths.
So I'm just gonna make a template.
Oh, God.
Don't wanna cut too much off.
So one, two, four... [frustrated sighs]
How's David got so much?
Oh, these are too small now.
[groans] Oh, this is a nightmare.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
[Steph] I don't know that
these are gonna be ready,
but I'm gonna have to do it now.
I think they feel solid enough
to actually take them out now.
[Alice] I think I'm gonna have to try
and take them out.
Turn the souffls out onto a baking sheet
and leave to rest.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, God.
I don't think this is gonna come out.
I've got no choice.
It's something.
Okay. Keep going, keep going.
[David] Oh, that one got
a bit of bottom on it.
Mm-mm.
What a palaver.
[Steph] Oh!
Well, cold water in the bain-marie
was not a good idea.
This is a bit embarrassing really,
isn't it?
Oh, dear.
[exhales] Pray for me.
[exhales]
I mean, like, do we keep going?
[crying] I just feel a bit stupid.
[Sandi] Bakers, you have...
Five minutes left
to complete your Stilton souffls.
[Alice] God, this was really mean
with timings.
This is the second bake but look,
it's a disaster.
[David] Let's see.
This is horrific.
Oh, dear.
That is going in there as well.
[David] These should take,
like, a minute to bake.
There's nowhere to put them but...
I can't fit 'em in, can I?
-[Sandi] Bakers...
-You have one minute left.
[Alice] Right, I'm gonna get 'em out.
[Steph] I don't know
whether to just get these out
'cause there's nothing gonna change
about this situation.
[sing-song] Panic stations.
[Steph] What a disaster.
Oh, dear.
It couldn't have gone much worse,
could it?
They're raw.
Seen better things in my life.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighs heavily]
Please bring you souffls up to the table
and place them behind your photograph.
[Noel] Prue and Paul are looking
for six beautifully-risen souffls,
accompanied by crisp lavosh crackers.
[Paul] We'll start with these.
These are risen, a little bit...
-Pale.
-pale. And the biscuits are a bit floppy.
-They were brought out the oven too early.
-[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] The souffl's got a little bit
of bounce to it.
It could've done with longer in the oven,
but there is some substance there.
I mean, it's stable enough.
But you can tell right in the middle,
there, it's underbaked.
[Prue] Good flavour.
Texture's too gluey.
If that was served to me at lunch,
I would eat it with a great deal
of pleasure. But this is the final.
-[Paul] Moving on to these, er...
-[Prue] Pancakes.
-Soups?
-[Prue chuckles]
[Paul] Yeah.
-The biscuits are too thick.
-And not baked enough.
[Paul] That's hardly been
in the oven. Look.
[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] They've had problems
with the souffl from the start.
They've beaten the whole thing to death.
Because those ingredients
are so delicious, it tastes lovely.
But it's like eating a sauce.
[Paul] Now, these look fairly substantial.
[cracks]
-Yeah, crack.
-[Paul] There is a break.
-[Prue] Lovely and thin.
-[Paul] They're not bad.
-[Paul] Nice colour.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] And they are baked through.
It's very much better,
but they're still not a perfect shape.
-[Paul] Mmm.
-That is delicious.
[Paul] Mmm. They're well baked, them.
[Sandi] Prue and Paul will now rank
our finalists' souffls
from worst to best.
Okay, in third place is...
-this one.
-So sorry. [chuckles]
[Prue laughs]
Your biscuits are too thick
and your souffls,
did they actually hit the oven?
I used cold water in my water bath.
-Cold water?
-Yeah.
Oh, bad luck, Steph.
In second place...
is this one. Alice.
These are a bit raw.
And the souffl,
they're a little bit uneven,
and could've done with a bit more cooking.
-Yeah.
-So, in first place, David.
Souffls are pretty good,
but you need to bake these longer.
But not a bad effort, actually.
[Steph] I just hope the baking fairies
are back for me tomorrow.
I think they might have gone off
for a drink already.
They need to come back in.
[Alice] Everything's just been
mediocre today.
Clumsy cake, gluey souffl.
Gotta make tomorrow, like,
the best thing I've ever made.
[David] Tomorrow,
knowing that there's gonna be
all our friends and family outside,
and it's the very last time
we can do anything to impress anyone...
yeah, that's high pressure.
[Sandi] There's just one more showstopper
for our final three bakers to complete.
Afterwards, at a special carnival party
in front of their family and friends,
we'll find out
this year's Baking Show champion.
But Alice has received
an upsetting phone call.
[Alice] Why was it cancelled?
Are they all cancelled?
Can you not get a flight from Dublin?
[Sandi] Her mum and dad
might not be able to make it.
I'm a little bit upset because my parents
are coming back from Ireland this morning
and their flight's just been cancelled.
And the thought of them not being here
when I walk out is just,
yeah, my worst nightmare, really.
So, I think the most consistent thing
about the entire series
is the number of times we've sat here
and gone,
"It's all down to the showstopper,"
because I think it is again.
It's literally little things now.
I think in the signature, Steph did okay.
flavours came through beautifully
-and it did look amazing.
-It looked fantastic.
[Paul] And then you have Alice.
Didn't look immaculate,
but it did taste good.
David, I think, where he let himself down
was literally the Armagnac.
But I actually think
David did a decent souffl.
David's was a lot better
than the other two.
[exhales]
For all the bakes they've done
this is the one that'll count.
-[Sandi] Yeah.
-They need to concentrate.
[Noel] There's a lot of stuff going on,
it's the final,
the families are coming down.
We've got a helter-skelter. [laughs]
-I'm gonna go on the helter-skelter.
-Shall we go on it now?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I think the four of us.
-In one sack.
That's your money shot, right there.
[Sandi and Noel laugh]
-[exhales]
-Hello, bakers.
It's time for your last ever challenge.
Today, the judges would like you to make
a deliciously deceptive feast,
in the form of a picnic basket
and its contents.
Your feast must contain elements
made from cake,
enriched bread and biscuit.
[Noel] The items in the basket
should deceive the eyes.
In other words, be made of
one kind of food but look like another.
So, basically, we're testing the theory
that we actually eat with our eyes.
I've been doing it for years.
It's messy, but it's okay.
[Sandi] Now, I do not need to remind you
this is your last chance
to impress the judges,
so you're going to need to display
exceptional creativity
and technical skills.
You have four and a half hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
[Sandi] Bake.
[Alice] My parents would hate the fact
that I was upset
because they weren't gonna be here.
So, focus.
There's so many elements today.
It's gonna be absolute carnage in here.
Absolute carnage.
[Steph] Bread's gonna look like a cake,
and then the cake's gonna look like bread.
It's gonna be all sorts
of confusion for you.
[Paul] I think the final challenge
is all about deception.
They could make a bread roll
look like a porkpie.
They could make a cake look like a banana.
But it's the final showstopper.
It's gotta taste and look fantastic.
All the techniques and all the decorations
that the bakers have dealt with
over the last ten weeks
are, sort of, summed up
in this one showstopper.
And what we want is really good bread,
really good cake, really good biscuits.
So, 29 challenges down, one to go.
And this is the big one for them.
May the best baker win.
-Hi, David.
-Hello, David.
-[Sandi] Good morning.
-Hello.
So, tell us about your picnic.
I'm making a cheeseboard out of biscuit,
and then making cheeses
out of lemon pound cake,
and then I'm making breads
to look like little peaches,
flavoured with saffron
and orange blossom water.
-Bingo. Bingo.
-[all laugh]
-[David] Only way.
It's honestly the only spice
in the whole thing.
[Noel] David's edible illusion picnic
will feature boozy fruit cup jellies
to accompany his peaches
made out of lightly spiced bread,
lemon pound cake cheeses
and fig rolls
that look like savoury sausage rolls.
I'm starting on my bread dough
'cause that takes quite a while.
Nik, my partner,
it's been his birthday this week.
And I had no time to celebrate with him.
So, this could be his birthday picnic.
One thing done!
[Sandi] David's not
the only one celebrating.
Whoo! Gotta pop the prosecco.
I love teaching, don't get me wrong,
but I love the summer holidays a lot.
So this is, kind of, my
end of the school year celebration picnic.
Tempted just to pour myself a glass.
[Sandi] Alice is turning her
celebratory prosecco into jellies
to go with strawberries
made out of raspberry-flavoured macarons,
orange and cardamom ice cream bread buns
and porkpie,
chicken drumsticks and scotch eggs
all created from carrot cake.
[Sandi] So the most important question,
who's coming to support you today?
Okay, so my parents...
[shakily] Don't,
'cause you'll make me cry again.
They were at a wedding
in Ireland, yesterday...
Sorry, you made me cry.
Oh, sweetie.
Erm, flight was cancelled this morning,
so I just really hope they make it.
But... I'm so embarrassed to cry.
-[Sandi] Oh.
-[Prue] Oh, darling.
[Paul] Are they, are they swimming, then?
I hope they swim or whatever to get here.
I just hope they're here.
-Yeah.
-I couldn't imagine it without them.
Biggest day of my life and everything,
erm, so...
As soon as they arrive,
I will make sure you know, okay?
-[Paul] Good luck, Alice. Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
Once I start crying I'm gone.
Like, I am gone.
[Steph] Right, focusing again.
[Noel] After struggling
with yesterday's technical...
I really do feel
like I'm baking for my life.
...Steph's hoping
there won't be any more tears today.
The dough looks different
to how it should do,
but I'm just gonna try and avoid
those negative thoughts.
[Noel] Steph's hopes of winning
are all pinned on her illusion picnic,
featuring spiced orange bread buns
turned into fairy cakes
and macaron strawberries.
Her savoury-looking centrepiece
will be a lemon poppy seed cake
chicken burger.
[Noel] I called you Mowgli. How are you?
I'm trying not to panic too much.
Just wanna be able to present something.
You will. You always do.
Yesterday was a bit touch and go,
wasn't it?
Hmm. All right. Well, look, carry on.
[Steph] That's gonna prove for an hour
first time round.
Oh, sorry.
[Sandi] As their bread dough proves...
So much to do and so little time.
...the bakers can move on
to their picnic centrepieces,
the illusion cakes.
[Steph] This is my lemon and poppy seed.
Quite a lot of lemon zest,
so just gonna zest for our lives.
Well, we've reached the final, Prue.
I think it's gonna be fascinating
to see what they come up with.
[Alice] I'm thinking of speed today,
so this is kind of an all-in-one mix.
I'm a bit worried about Alice.
She's worried about whether her parents
will get on that plane.
She needs to just concentrate on the plan
and keep baking.
So these are lemon spice drops.
So instead of having to
sit and zest a lemon,
you can put these in,
and it gives
a really intense lemon flavour.
I think David seems to be
in a much calmer place.
[Prue] Yeah. Always looks as if
he's enjoying himself, doesn't he?
He does seem the most chilled
out of the three.
[Steph] Doesn't taste lemony enough,
so must need more lemon.
[Prue] I just really want
all three to do well
because if you just crash out,
it's horrible.
I totally agree.
Oh!
There's only gonna be one champion.
Who's it gonna be?
No idea at the moment.
No, me neither.
These are going in.
I think it tastes of lemon. I don't know.
I think I'm gonna have to go with it.
On 180 for about 30 minutes.
[Alice] Okay, right, let's clear
some stuff out the way.
This is unheard of. [chuckles]
[Noel] Bakers, you have three hours left.
-Phew.
-Keep going.
[Noel] With their breads...
These are gonna prove again.
...and cakes underway...
[Alice] Need a bit longer.
...the bakers can begin their final
picnic transformation. The biscuit.
What are you folding that with?
Erm...
Hmm?
Wooden spoon.
I might get a spatula.
[David] Fig rolls
are my favourite biscuit.
It's funny 'cause when we did it
at biscuit week,
Jamie put an egg wash on his fig roll
and Paul joked
that it's like a sausage roll
so, I was like, "Ah, okay, perfect.
Well, I'll make sausage rolls."
So I'm making my macarons.
Strawberries and tomatoes,
but they're gonna be
raspberry and lemon flavoured.
I think Steph's also doing
a strawberry macaron. That's okay.
Everyone has strawberries at a picnic.
This is the Italian method
that I did last week.
I can't make them using the French method.
These are going in the fridge.
I need to let them rest for half an hour.
[Sandi] But there'll be
no rest for the bakers.
[whimpers] Where am I up to?
[Alice] Very much multi-tasking now.
And this is all about illusion, isn't it?
So, I don't wanna rush decoration.
[David] Cakes are looking good.
So, they're all coming out.
They're quite caramelised and colourful.
No, it's still lovely and soft
in the middle.
[Steph] Hmph. Wow.
Oh, that's so dry. Ugh, God.
How bad can things go wrong?
[Sandi] Steph's cake
isn't her only problem.
Oh, wait...
[Sandi] Her macarons
aren't going to plan either
[voice breaking] I think that's
too liquid. I haven't got time to redo it.
Look at the state of it. It's just so bad.
All of it.
I don't know how I can get through this.
Ow.
-[Noel] You all right?
-[Steph] No, sorry.
-I'm having a real stress--
-Don't be sorry.
I've just got too much to do.
-[Noel] You've gotta dig deep.
-[Steph] I am. I am.
[Noel] This is the last time
you're gonna do this.
-I'm gonna try.
-You've won star baker four times.
-I know.
-You got this.
-Just keep going.
-Okay, thank you.
-Thank you.
-Calm. Calm?
I'm trying to. Calm. Calm.
[Noel laughing]
Bakers, you're halfway through!
Stop mucking about, it's the final.
Ugh, it's like glue. I still don't know
that that's worked properly.
I wouldn't say in control. The worst bits
are still to come. Nougatine-gate.
[Noel] As well as an array of breads,
cakes and biscuits...
I think I'm actually gonna start
my nougatine, which is terrifying.
...our three finalists have been asked to
make a nougatine basket
to display their illusion picnics.
[David] So, nougatine is a caramel
that encases lots of nuts or seeds
and goes really hard.
So, I'm using sesame seeds as my filler.
It's starting to smell a little bit burny,
so I think that's a good sign.
I'm just wiping down the edges
'cause it's started to crystallise.
-[Sandi] Oh, and that's a bad thing?
-Yeah.
-[Sandi] Any news?
-No news as of yet, so...
Oh, God. Tears coming again.
Eyes are like a tap.
Good luck, everyone.
[Alice] Please work, nougatine.
[Steph] So sticky.
[David] So, the key bit for this
is not getting burnt.
Ow! It's so hot.
[David] That I think is ready.
[Alice] This is what I'm gonna mould
my nougatine around.
[Steph] This has gone really badly
in practice,
so, I just feel like this is gonna be
a disaster.
[Alice] It's a bit skew-whiff,
but it's on now.
Ugh. How do you do this?
I didn't make a handle at home.
I just presumed it was easy.
Don't do this to me.
Ooh, I should probably do it
a different way.
[Steph] I mean, this is not a hamper.
I don't think a handle's gonna happen.
[David] Just burnt myself
a couple of times,
but everything looks clean and neat.
Oh, my...
He's insane isn't he?
Tell you what.
Your driving's getting better.
-Thanks for teaching me.
-Yeah, no, it's fine. It's just, erm...
It's not a criticism,
but I think we took a slight wrong turn.
-What do you mean?
-Well, erm,
we're not in the funfair any longer.
-[chuckling] Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
Bakers, you have one hour, just one hour.
[gasps]
It's all a bit blurry, really.
We were going quite fast.
Yes.
My macarons gonna go in
for about 12 to 14 I think.
[Alice] I'm just
worried about the macarons.
They need to form a film over the top,
and that's how when they rise,
they hold their shape,
but these are not...
I don't know whether to do them again.
Maybe I have time, I don't know.
[Sandi] Her macarons
might not be going to plan,
but there is some good news for Alice.
[Alice] Are my parents on the plane?
[crewman speaking]
Yes!
Yay! Right, I'm gonna start them again.
[utensils clatter]
Okay. Go, go, go.
[David] The buns are gonna be out
in a couple of minutes
and then these will go in.
[Alice] Round two.
Let's just see how these ones go.
Right, move on.
[Steph] I don't think my macarons
are properly baked.
They're really bad.
It's just not my day is it?
[Alice] So, this is how my cake
should've gone yesterday.
This one, however,
needs to look like a porkpie.
[David] So, this one is cheddar.
[Steph] So, this is just toasted coconut
for my chicken burger.
[Alice] So I'm just gonna crimp the edge,
then I'm gonna spray paint it.
[David] Just want to add
a little bit of texture to this one.
[Steph] I'm going for a golden bun look.
[Alice] Okay.
[speaking normally]
Right, there we go. Porkpie done.
As far as I'm concerned, that's cheese.
I'm just gonna make this
into a blue cheese.
Look at you.
You're just straight in there. Boom.
-You're not scared are you?
-No.
You seem to be going great guns,
so I'm gonna leave you alone.
-Cool, thanks Noel.
-I'll come back when you're panicking,
-but I don't think that'll ever happen.
-No.
[Sandi] Bakers!
Half an hour left. Half an hour.
[David] Go, Alice. Go, Alice.
I don't know
if I'm gonna get it done in half an hour,
but just keep going.
Never give up.
Some iced buns.
[David] My peaches.
They were slightly overproved,
so they've got
a bit of a rim round them.
[Alice] My macarons,
they've kind of formed a seal.
Just gonna put the other ones in as well.
Oh, God.
They're slightly baked biscuits.
I don't have time to redo them.
That's fine.
[Alice] Fill these scotch eggs. [sighs]
[Steph] The buns look overbaked,
just like everything's
a little bit overbaked. [sighs]
[Alice] I've got literally everything done
apart from my macarons,
and if I don't have them,
then I haven't met the brief.
So...
that's not good, is it?
-[Sandi] Bakers!
-You've got ten minutes left.
Ten minutes.
I'm not happy with how I've baked stuff,
the overall look,
but it's not been my day.
Piece of wax paper for the cheese.
[Alice] Now I don't have time for this.
Kind of gonna do it anyway.
[David] Prue and Paul.
Right, well, they're awful,
but there's something there.
[David] They are looking delightful.
I'm gonna scrap the strawberries
and just do tomatoes.
[Steph] Rustic is the order of the day.
[softly] Two, one, time.
Bakers, that is it for 2019.
[exhales]
Please place your picnic baskets
at the end of your station.
-Well done, kids. You made it.
-[Sandi] You did it!
[exhales]
[Noel] Outside the tent,
our finalists' family and friends
have arrived
along with some familiar faces.
It's amazing to be back. I'm so excited.
I feel like I need a nap. [laughing]
[Jamie] I missed everyone massively.
Feel like I was missing out,
bit of FOMO. [laughs]
It's so lovely to see everyone.
We just need the last three out now.
My money's on... [exhales heavily]
Essex. I'm rooting for Alice.
For the boys, I'm gonna back Dave.
Big Dave.
[Michelle] David is so knowledgeable.
To bring home the win today,
that'd just be magical for him.
Steph's just obliterated that tent,
hasn't she?
I don't know. I don't know.
I... I couldn't call it today.
Any three of them totally worthy.
Oh, argh, I don't know.
All of them. I choose all of them.
They're all my winners.
[Sandi] It's judgment time
for the showstopping
edible picnic illusions.
Alice, please bring up your showstopper.
Not as strong as I thought I was.
[chuckles nervously]
I think that's exceptional.
Quite an impressive illusion.
Yeah. The scotch eggs, you do believe
that that's egg.
That's amazing. The only thing that fail
a little on the illusion side
are the ice creams.
They're very good.
They just don't look totally convincing.
[Paul] Let's have a look at the buns.
I don't think it really works
'cause blueberries
don't have much flavour,
but they do look absolutely perfect.
-[Paul] And these are?
-[Alice] Carrot cake scotch eggs.
So, the egg is a lemon cream cheese
and then a lemon curd yolk.
-Lemon comes through a little bit.
-Hmm.
-Good carrot cake there.
-Mmm.
[Prue] I think that's exceptional.
The illusion works,
it's funny and it tastes nice.
[Paul] And these are the little macarons?
[Prue] You only got one strawberry-shaped.
I did have a few issues
with the macarons. [chuckles]
[Prue chuckles]
That's really strong flavour,
really fresh fruit.
[Paul] Right, what is this?
It's orange and cardamom.
-Love that. A lot of zest coming off that.
-Mmm.
A lot of zing. It's a good texture as well
for an enriched dough.
Very clever,
and I do like the taste of them.
Thank you very much, Alice.
That's a pretty good effort.
-Well done.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
David, please bring up your showstopper.
I think it looks amazing.
Stunning. The basket is great.
It's even got mine
and Prue's initials on it.
The fig rolls have worked really well
as sausage rolls.
And that cheese looks incredible.
-So, what shall we start with? The peach?
-[Prue] Yeah, let's start with the peach.
Oh, that looks lovely.
I like. That's really clever.
And the saffron does work well.
-[David] Yes!
-And it took the final to get there.
The texture's excellent as well,
and the fruit just sets it off
with a little bit of zing as well.
I think the flavours are very interesting.
But I think they're too chewy.
[Paul] Shall we try your fig rolls,
or sausage rolls?
Mmm. Very nice.
-That's very good as well.
-[Prue] And they look fantastic.
[Paul] Yeah, they do.
The texture's so soft on the mouth
with the fondant and with the buttercream
as well all together.
-It is really delicious.
-[Prue] It's really delicious.
You've come up with something
that is very very clever,
and you've gone to the extra bit
of making the biscuit base
and the fondant, the tablecloth,
the chutney.
And the whole thing together
is exceptional.
Bravo.
Thank you.
Nailed it.
Phew.
Steph, would you like to bring up
your showstopper, please?
Apart from the basket having had
a few problems,
I like the look of the burger.
And I would definitely think
that was made of bread.
I think there's obviously been
a few issues today.
The bun topping is not right.
And the strawberries, you need to get
the glisten on the top of them.
The bun I like,
and that looks pretty good.
Nice hot cross bun.
Delicious. Love the spice.
[Paul] Need to prove a little bit more.
-It's a little bit tight inside.
-[Steph] Hmm.
[Prue] Those are not round enough
for strawberries. They're a bit flat.
[smack lips] My, you've got a kick
to that Chantilly, haven't you?
[Prue] What's in there?
-[Steph] Cherry liqueur.
-It's a little bit overwhelming.
Yeah.
-[Noel whispers] Wow.
-[Paul laughing]
[Prue] That is really good.
-[Sandi] That's great.
-[Paul] Clever.
[Prue] Very clever.
It's not much flavour to that.
-Okay.
-[Paul] Could've done with more lemon.
It's a little bit overbaked as well.
Never mind, Steph.
Thank you very much indeed.
[Steph sniffles]
Sorry.
[Steph chuckles]
Doesn't matter, all right?
-[chuckles and sniffles] I know. Thanks.
-You did a good job.
It's fine.
[indistinct chatter]
[Sandi] At the Baking Show funfair...
-Oh!
-[bell dings]
...the crowd are awaiting
Paul and Prue's final decision.
This is difficult for us
'cause we just get to look at the cakes,
we don't taste them.
If there was one that you particularly
loved the taste of, which one would it be?
I liked Alice's. And I liked David's.
I'm not sure what happened to Steph today
because there are some issues
in every single element.
-She'll be kicking herself.
-It was heartbreaking, really, wasn't it?
[Prue] It was heartbreaking.
I think ultimately what we're looking at,
it's between Alice and David.
-So, Alice has had star baker twice.
-[Paul] Yeah.
David, not at all.
I think the thing is, with David,
they always look good,
but it's whether it matches up
with flavour and textures,
and often it didn't,
but in the final it has.
-Cool.
-But I'm going to remind you
that his signature was not your favourite.
If you're looking overall,
Alice has been very steady
-in every single challenge.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-She has.
-The Scotch egg is astonishing.
[Paul] The look of it throws you
totally when you eat it.
Well, I think you two
have still got things to discuss,
so while you do that,
can I have a sausage roll, please?
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
-[Noel chuckles]
-[Sandi] Thanks.
-You do know it's a fig roll, don't you?
-Oh, I've changed my mind.
-Ah.
[all cheering and applauding]
-Oh, my goodness, there's loads of people!
-[Steph] Oh, my God!
[Sandi] Before the winner
of the Great British Baking Show 2019
is announced...
Hey, bakers!
...the bakers can at last
join their family and friends.
You made it! Oh, my God!
[Alice] I'm ecstatic that all my friends
and family are here.
-Love you.
-[Alice chuckles]
So, I can relax now. [chuckles]
[Alice] I was so scared
that you weren't gonna come.
-I know. Wouldn't miss it for the world.
-[Alice laughs] I know.
I've done 30 bakes in the Bake Off tent,
and the last one, it went well,
so, really relieved and happy.
Oh, my darling, come here.
[Steph] I'm proud of myself.
I really have gone above and beyond
anything I could've imagined. [sniffles]
I saved the worst till last.
[indistinct chatter]
Maybe ten weeks was just one too many.
[Nik] This looks amazing.
[David] I think in other weeks
when I've done well,
I've never felt like I've done the best.
So, I feel more nervous
than I have in any other week.
[Jamie] You've glazed
your fig rolls, mate.
[all laughing]
I'll be happy no matter what,
I would just like to be ecstatic.
[crowd cheering and applauding]
Would the finalists please step forward.
Thank you so much to all of you
for coming to support
this wonderful event.
And how lovely to see all the bakers
returned to the tent.
I am delighted to tell you,
after ten weeks of intense competition,
the winner is...
David.
[crowd cheering loudly]
[David laughing]
[indistinct chatter]
-[Alice] You deserve it.
-Oh, my goodness.
[Paul and David laughing]
[Paul] Well done, mate.
-You smashed it.
-[David sighs]
-Just at the right time.
-Yeah, don't smash that, though.
-[David laughs] Thank you.
-Oh.
-Well done, darling.
Thank you very much.
-So well done!
-Whoa!
-Thank you. Thank you.
-[Sandi] Congratulations.
[laughs] I got it.
I got it.
[indistinct chatter]
[Sandi] So close. It was so close.
[exhales]
-[Michael] Yes! You won it!
-[David laughs]
It wasn't even in my mind
that I could win this.
So proud of you.
Like, week-on-week,
other people were stronger,
I was always the underdog,
but managing to get through.
Just getting to the final
was a win for me.
So this is just unreal.
-[Noel] Nailed it, in the final.
-[David sighs]
Yeah, just saved the best till last,
that's all I had.
David came as probably the underdog
into the final,
knowing that twice Alice has won,
four times Steph has won,
and he has come from nothing,
and then won the whole thing.
I mean, it's priceless.
Absolutely priceless.
He should be very proud of himself.
I think he's done an amazing job.
[photographer] Lovely!
Thank you very much.
-Cool.
-[Paul] Well, done, David.
-Whoa. Thank you very much.
-[Paul] What are you going to do now?
-[laughs] I don't know.
-[Paul laughs]
David is an extraordinary baker.
I am so full of admiration for him,
because right from the beginning,
he has never lost his temper,
he is always very neat and very organised.
It was really a question
of the tortoise catching the hare
because he just steadily went on
and... and won.
-Oh, my goodness!
-[David chuckles]
You're amazing. We're so proud of you.
[David sighs] You can take these, Mum.
You can have these.
David just... He blew us out of the water.
The best baker won,
and I'm feeling great.
-You did so well. I'm so proud.
-I am so happy.
I am really proud of myself, and I can
really leave with my head held high.
It's just the best feeling.
Well done, Steph.
If you were gonna have a bad day,
how better to make it all go away.
I've made some amazing,
lifelong friends.
Just the most incredible experience ever.
Ah. It feels so good.
It's been weeks and weeks of intensity,
and fatigue, and then intensity.
And to finish it with this, I mean,
it's the best feeling in the world.
-Well done, David.
-[David laughs]
Thank you.
You got the bread, honey.
-[David] I got the bread.
-[Nik laughs]
I'm so proud of you.